there is a lot to buy in cyberpunk 2077
cars guns consumables and most
importantly
cybernetics most cybernetics offer
passive buffs however there are a few
that can fundamentally change the way
you play
here are some cybernetics that are worth
your hard earned eddies
don't forget to like and subscribe for
more cyberpunk tips
reinforce tendons aka double jump
there are two cybernetics that improve
these jump but there is
only one worth buying reinforced tendons
this gives v a double jump the other one
is a charge jump which is cool but
doesn't give you as much control
there are a handful of cool cybernetics
but i found this one to be the most
useful for my playstyle
not only does this make v more agile in
combat but it changes the way you
explore night city
there are even some areas of this city
where you can avoid the winding roads
altogether and leap from building the
building like the cyber ninja you've
always wanted to be reinforced tendons
also make infiltration gigs
far easier in most cases you can leap
onto the roof
open the skylight and complete the
objective without anyone ever
seeing you this particular upgrade is
common among ripper docks across night
city
the vendors in city center watson and
santo domingo
also rare variants of the reinforced
tendons upgrade which will set you back
45 000 eddies
gorilla arms aka more strength there are
four major arm cybernetics in cyberpunk
2077 but gorilla arms might be the most
useful
in and out of combat if you're
struggling with the janky boxing
missions i highly recommend picking up a
pair of these bad boys
your punches will be a lot deadlier and
no one will call you out on it so
technically it's not even cheating
i'll rip that tongue out according to
the in-game description
gorilla arms also let you rip open
specific doors and yank turrets from
their base
but you can perform both those actions
if your body attribute is high enough
even without gorilla arms
i'm not sure if that's a bug or an
oversight the developers missed
either way gorilla arms are worth your
eddies hell you could even make
all your money back fairly quickly by
betting high on the fistfights
if you want a low end version of the
gorilla arms you can find it from the
first stripper dock victor in watson
however if you want a legendary version
of the gorilla arms you can find it at
another ripper dock in the west side of
the city center
this variant is a massive upgrade
compared to the base versions but you'll
need to have 45 street cred and a lot of
eddies in order to purchase it
projectile launch system aka wrist
rockets
if you prefer spectacle over utility
then might i interest you in the
projectile launch system
this upgrade allows v to shoot rockets
out of their wrists
neat the major drawback of this ability
is that it replaces your grenades but
who needs grenades when you have a
rocket launcher with infinite ammo and
virtually no cooldown
built into your wrists in order to use
the projectile launch system you will
also need cyberware that enables
smartlink
you can find this arm upgrade from
different ripper docks around night city
including
victor and watson karensukov
aka bullet time
any solo with a focus on reflexes should
make this a
priority this nervous system cyberware
upgrade will slow down time by 90
for up to 3.5 seconds when blocking
aiming or attacking
during a dodge or slide maneuver the
karenzakov is useful for combat
encounters when you're facing multiple
foes or elite enemies and want to slow
down the pace to deal
extra damage if you want the best
karenzakov money can buy you'll need to
have 18 points in reflexes for your
character
once you meet that requirement you can
find this upgrade from the ripper dock
in santo domingo on the west end of the
district
this one in particular is a legendary
upgrade costing upwards of 35 000 eddies
so make sure you have enough money
saved up cyberdex aka a netrunner's best
friend
[Music]
if you're playing as a netrunner you
should always keep your eyes peeled for
better cyber decks
your cyber deck determines how much base
ram you have and how many quick hacks
you can equip
the cyber deck v starts with the game is
to put it bluntly
awful upgrading that stock cyber deck
should be a priority if you are just
starting the game and want to play as a
sneaky hacker
ripper docks all over night city sell
cyberdeck so stop by as many as possible
some are very expensive and require high
street cred so if you find one you like
make a mental note and return later on
there's a ton of cyberware in cyberpunk
2077
but these are the ones we found most
useful if there's one you like let us
know in the comments below and for more
cyberpunk 2077
subscribe to the channel
[Music]